I think we would now might be live all
right we know my chair right at mayor
welcome members of the committee other
members are people who are watching to
this meeting a special meeting of the
community and resources committee I'm
gonna move right on forward we've got no
fire alarms or anything to worry about
so we move on to the agenda
number one apologies oh sorry chair no
apologies right proper job item number
two publications no one asking to speak
but we have five written submissions
which I've asked that the staff read out
jfi if I heard you though we've actually
got seven contributions received written
contributions which of us to be read out
ordinarily obviously that's limited to
six but that's at the discretion of the
chair so jfu contends that we go with
all seven contributions I'll read them
out yes happy with that okay so I'll
read them out in the the order they were
received so the first one is from Bryn
and Jane wrath of inside 11 a 11 a south
streets tour in turn we would like to
support the proposal to suspend the
parking charges in torrid during these
very difficult times when the paper
relaying was being done in Torrance and
last year the contractors felt the need
to close the entire road off footfall
dropped massively overnight due to lack
of short-term parking the torrent and
chamber of trades took it upon ourselves
to finance parking up to one hour to try
and alleviate the problem customers
simply had to produce their parking
ticket at whiskers pet store for a full
refund many took advantage of this and
the footfall and business of the town
was restored it was a very successful
experiment
obviously the chamber of trades could
not continue this subsidy subsidy in
perpetuity parking charges do make a
difference particularly to people who
are just popping in for a short time we
need to be encouraging local people to
use their local facilities now more than
ever by suspending parking charges it
will make a difference every piece of
evidence leads to this the second is
received from great torrents in town
council entitle C in our committee 13th
of July 2020
great torrents and Town Council members
understand that at the above meeting
torij District Council's
members will consider councillor McGough
motion and set out below counselor
counselor Burgas motion considered
members at full council on Monday 22nd
June and approved read as given the
recent pandemic and huge financial
strain it has put on our local business
owners I would like to see TDC support
our businesses to encourage football
back into their premises in the town
centers we can help towards this by
continuing free parking for two months
thus given him a small support cushion
through this enabling phase of opening
business back up great Taunton town
council members at great torrents in
Town Council's council meeting on the
25th of June 2020 voted to support this
motion and demonstrate this support by
advising tourists District Council of
the same three Torrington hosts a number
of small independent shops and
businesses
have been closed for a number of limited
or no reserves whilst the national grand
scheme would have assisted these
businesses when most of them were closed
we are now very conscious that as they
start to reopen they will remain
pressures for a number of reasons - fall
is key to the success of these local
businesses and anything that will
encourage people to visit the local
shops and amenities is welcomed over the
past few months people have got over the
habit of venturing outdoors and we now
see and we see no with a lifting of
restrictions people remain nervous of
stepping outside we know from feedback
over the years the parking charges are a
drawback for people using cars to visit
the town centre at a time when we need
to help get businesses back up and
running it is critical that we endeavour
to help remove any obstacles we can we
currently have the added issue that
people are nervous about having to walk
too far and or cut a bus into the town
centre in fact government guidance
encourages the use of either a cycle or
car rather than public transport free
parking would help facilitate use of a
car which again will help football in
the town centre we have worked with
tourist district council and the chamber
of Trade over these past few weeks in
preparation for reopening of
non-essential businesses and the
hospitality sector and we have been
grateful for their input free parking
for a period of time would be hugely
welcomed and positive extension of this
work therefore in the interest of
promoting increased footfall and spend
in our own town centre thus helped in
the myriad of small businesses to get up
and run in following on in a fourth
shutdown the Town Council fully supports
the motion to continue with free parking
in Sydney House and barley Grove car
parks prefer the two months we would
like this representation to be presented
to members
the motion please acknowledge receipt of
this notice aboard your sincerely comes
luckily Allen mayor of going torrent and
the third one from Allen Cartwright of
Hartland Forest Golf Club wall Zuri
Biddeford dear Sean the cove in nineteen
impact has been disastrous for many
people in businesses however I imagine
that the financial impact on TDC is also
absolutely huge to TDC exists to serve
the whole populace but principally its
area of concern and must also be to
serve the less fortunate members of our
society the aged and infirm for example
TDC therefore needs in these dreadful
times to safeguard his own income in
order to do so the loss of almost a
hundred thousand pound per month in
parking revenue is extremely significant
to CDC however the cost of parking for
an hour or two for almost all visitors
to the town center is not which is most
important TDC loses a hundred thousand
pounds per month or I pay a few quid to
park I urge the safeguarding of the
local authority revenue as best you can
including Park charges I'm sure it will
be much diminished anyway in for a few
once more just my two pens two pence
worth kind regards Allen Cartwright
fourth one from Janine downs of
collectability on the square and REE
parking - increased footfall in great
Torrington as a retailer in Toronto and
I am of course pleased that your
planning help for us instead of free
parking for a period of two months why
not just charge over charged one pound
for two hours the thinking behind this
suggestion is people say to me daily
that they must
as the 30 minutes of the meet on the
meter is due to run out so they rush off
this would keep people in the town
longer and hopefully missed' visit more
shops and perhaps meet for a coffee etc
also I must tell you that when you open
the car park for free the car park car
parks just fill up with cars belonging
to residents who get free parking all
day leave in very little room for
shoppers and visitors as a retired
retail analyst working on solutions in
footfall and customer flow I do have
experience in this area it may be by
getting the car park charges changed to
a simpler menu you may find when you do
the sums that you might increase income
I might add that if most of the shops
did not close at 1:00 p.m. every day
customers would also come into town in
the afternoon we are open every day from
10:00 a.m. until 4:00 p.m. our takings
are almost non-existent after 1:00 p.m.
so part of the problem is the retailer's
themselves I will be in the shop while
the meeting takes place so will be
unable to attend
I hope my comments are of help I look
forward to the outcome of the meeting
best regards Jeanine domes and the next
one addressed to tourist district
council community Resources Committee we
the undersigned support the motion to be
debated on Monday the 13th of July by
the above committee we believe that a
continuation of free parking in town
centers will help increase the footfall
to our towns giving our businesses a
chance to get back on their feeds during
these exceptional exceptionally
difficult times we look forward to
hearing outcome of this meeting many
thanks great torrents and con yet market
traders next one from Katherine a walk
shot dear council
as an attending public may introduce
myself my name is Catherine WAP shot I
am the owner of the unique boutique in
Torrington and I'm chair of the great
Torrington chamber of trade
I support the motion put forward to the
council ie that a further two months of
free parking should be made available
two Tauruses town centers to help
kick-start the local economy it is not
clear whether this would be all day free
Park in one hour free Park Inn or just
or two hours free parking but free
parking at any level would be greatly
appreciated I also think that a
councilman must have looked forward to
beyond the proposed two-month extension
by considering a permanent free to our
Park in this would definitely encourage
the public to shop locally and would
give more time to shop
considering that observe in social
distance in means queues everywhere
however it must be stressed that free
park in per se would be greatly welcomed
by the traders of Torrington and I thank
the TDC for bringing this issue to the
fore at this time yours faithfully
Katherine a wash off finally a statement
from Emily whop shot I wanted to comment
briefly on my support for a proposal of
free parking extension in torrid for car
parks I live directly in the center of
great Torrington just off the main
square with an amused development I have
to cross the square to get in and out I
have a dog that I walk extensively on
the columns there in lockdown whilst
people were restricted today one out to
the day there was a steady but small
flow of people in the mornings but in
the afternoons everything closed as
things began to ease but whilst parking
was still free it started to get busier
in the term what was interesting was the
way the people appeared to use the term
changed people came in and bought their
pet
brought their pets or families for
exercise combined in this with their
shop if it was busier people went for a
walk first and then returned to the
shops this pattern of use was more
evenly spread across the weekend
throughout the day I have have had
various conne stainless conversations
with people around the town as well as
when out dog walk in and generally the
feeling was that you were much safer
shop in his small local shops here in
the openness where that in a supermarket
and people found it convenience to go
out after or before or as well it was
clear that many from small communities
will come into Torrington instead of
taking longer journeys to supermarkets
in the bigger towns a key comment was
always that there was great to her freak
park in and how convenient it was to be
able to come to Torrington now whilst a
few Saturday mornings were busier than
his ideal for social distance in
generally it felt positive for the town
that people were out again to some
extent as soon as the charging came back
into car parks the number of visitors
immediately dropped now a partner's a
village two people coming in very
briefly to minimize the cost and trying
to rush and go to the post office and
all the shops at once and then then
leave straightaway what this inevitably
does is create recreates real pinch
points which tend to be Monday Friday
and Saturday mornings particularly with
long queues form the narrow pavements of
our historic town are such that social
distance in is just not possible
and was the one way system was installed
it has simply been ignored as four
antennas cars driving through people
cannot use the road space and cross in
the square certain times is hazardous
now due to trapped queues of people wait
in those that have the luxury are
leaving shopping until the end the very
end of the day or there is a race to get
the shop to get to the shops as they
open many older people who live
we feel quite trapped as they're not
confident in walking in or around the
tone with so many people as they are so
anxious about contracting the virus the
Oprah shops are struggling with the
pressures of the busy times and staying
safe and sticking to the regulations it
is stressful throw everyone free parking
will take the time and take a time
pressure off and people can visit when
and where they want chair that's all
these are public contributions that's
fine so looking at the agenda
declarations of interest you all know
the score I think it's a case that we're
all entitled to speak on this one in
that it's of general concern someone
will tell me if I'm wrong but there we
are
is that right Steve I'm sure I'll be
fair for members to determine whether
they have a particular interest or not
to declare okay
right item four were not proposing any
part two items item five urgent matters
I'll just make it clear that this
meeting comes about because I made the
decision that it couldn't be added to
the last C&R it was too late to allow
the officers to repair the report which
you've now received so I take
responsibility for that one and we move
on to the one important item tonight
item six notice of motion councillor
McGough made the proposal and I'm gonna
hand over now to no cancel McGrath
should have his speak at this stage
surely he made the proposal in full
council
mr. chairman I do appreciate chances
getting to speak first
I thank an officer saw you putting the
report together in their quick time that
we did obviously you see if I read the
report I don't agree with some of it
some of the report there but it is there
in front of us I wanted touch if I want
to touch on the lead members report here
at councillor Claire Horton who's the
deputy leader of the council she puts in
four bullet points here the loss of
income will require removal reduction of
financial revenue support from another
of the councils approved service
projects well we all know as a council
we sat on a reserve pot of ten million
for capital program which I'm sure most
of people horizontal actually we're
actually got planning to do now the
motion that was put before us was trying
to give the business owners and the town
centre is a revival and it's over this
pandemic time just try my best to
actually put this motor for it's
actually improved there's you know the
lives of the residents in there now
within the port is that report sorry it
touches on points of we're only looking
after car owners now I don't I don't
agree with slightest because when we
give financial support several fractions
of the community whether it be sports
clubs whether it be art galleries
theaters they all deserve the support
we're doing and to me is it okay comes
across under ninety two thousand pounds
that's me to get our local economy up
and running again it's money well spent
now our job you know I get so wide life
but is most emotion forward well there's
36 verse on district council and Clare
Hortons report about Westwood home not
being mentioned into this it wasn't a
case of trying to pick on tourism parts
his tourism areas like Westwood ho
actually received good financial
contributions they just had a car park
an investment of nearly a million pound
over the past few years which was
conservative-led and that investments go
on into westward ho now I'm a local boy
born and bred I'm all for any
investments any area I believe is a time
for counselors to pull together to show
your communities they actually work in
their best interests at heart
one of the points that really
where we could find finally it was the
last point but a point for finally know
over devon district or indeed the county
council are offering free car parking
well we are tourist district council
we're own district council we're own
mind own views and own campuses a
non-public we don't need to rely on
debbie County Council to bring some
before us which we can do ourselves and
the other Devon districts were I'm sorry
I don't I don't agree was the slightest
any comment about free parking wouldn't
help I spoke to mr. Rob Braddock of
Westward Ho who's got a free car park in
Westwood ho and the benefits have been
absolutely exemplary for his business to
theorists this is proof that free
parking just for the two two month
period but his is obviously longer took
period he's been it you know benefit his
own pocket but improves his business it
works now that's sort of like safe a
moment making miss chim thank you
right I'm gonna hand over I guess it
Shawn taking this one is it yeah yeah
Thank You chair well and we're all now
familiar with the notice of motion has
been proposed by counselor from a golfer
two months oh sorry yeah two months free
parking in our time centers the report
in front of you is designed to give you
enough information to debate that today
and come to a conclusion for yourselves
the body of the main body of the report
in front of you provides you with some
tables where we've looked at last year's
takings to give you an indication of how
much free parking might cost so therein
lies the dilemma with this that nothing
is truly free and to sort of pick up on
a point that pendulum thought was just
making their mr. Braddock actually pays
us for the privilege of providing free
parking for his to his customers in in
Westborough so isn't free those analysis
come out with a figure of a hundred and
ninety two thousand pounds in Biddeford
Torrington and hopefully we we don't
know if that's accurate we don't know
quite how this year was going to pan out
in terms of trading but what we do know
is that it's going to be a significant
cost if we don't take
and display income and that pain display
income does help supplement or
discretionary services across the
console the other implications are
permits we probably need to extend and
perhaps refund some permit income and
obviously we've just done that for for
the two months that we were not
enforcing before on the car parts to do
it again is significant loss to the
council I haven't costed that into those
figures and also significant inputs for
the team small admin team that run the
car parking services
councilman I've mentioned the other
Devon districts like I say we could have
done some analysis and most districts or
all districts aren't providing free car
payment car parking but most districts
are taking the opportunity to revive
that income stream again to find income
to support those other discretionary
services and and really important things
that we provide to our communities there
were a range of implications set out in
the report
most of particular most in particular
picked up on by cancer Hudson in her
comments was about equality the quality
of offering for the whole of the
district and again cancer McGough
reference that and also shall we pick up
on the compliance with other policies
and strategies it's not really in
accordance encouraging car journeys with
our climates decoration so that's an
important consideration for you to have
jaunt you just wanna stop a second we
got cubs latitudes and comes with Jones
who have they hand up right I would have
thought it was fair to let Shaun take it
right through myself I just they just
check in to make sure it wasn't an
interest they would declare in or
anything chaired you know if you want to
just check that okay we'd better check
that with them but my view is let's hear
the officer report and then move into a
debate what are they
to say Chancellor Hutchings was one and
I was getting ready to comment as I put
my hand up but I have to declare HS well
because I am a trader in hos way thank
you
who else was it with the hand up it was
me Chet no I was just doing the same
thing as John get ready to comment later
thank you oh right carry on Shawn okay
Thank You chair council Hudson's
obviously provided a comment that
everyone has been able to see and that's
there for you to consider so the
conclusions the conclusion section of
this report and the summary basically
major on the debate of whether free
parking is the a appropriate or right
way to stimulate Town Center trading
activity or driver footballers
councillor McGough referenced in his
notice of motion some train of thought
is that it does our research would
suggest that that's more relevant to
out-of-town trading sensors rather than
Town Center trading centers where car
parking can often be limited and it's
more important to have a frequent
turnover of car parking spaces which
help is helped by appropriate charging
no charging leads me on to a point where
we've done a bit of analysis across the
county and for instance we we think
we're quite reasonable in terms of our
car parking charges and on average
because the market turns at Devon we're
about twenty pence an hour cheaper than
most other districts so the other the
other points of reference in there I
think chair is that if you're not going
to well if you don't consider this free
parking is the right way to stimulate
economic activity and that's for you to
decide upon we think and have been
trying to stimulate action in our town
centres through our opening up
activities and also through our plans to
revitalize the towns with a future high
street fund bid and the globe bearded
Torrington and things like that which
are obviously funded did completely
despair
Connect activity but funded by by money
that can be derived from car parking
amongst other things so I won't labor
too long when those appoint me what
you've always shimon but doing the
report it's in the collusion sex use it
so i just at this i can follow it so it
so i just come back sorry we're better
oh so i'm sorry i just running through
the conclusion section in the summary
section so there's three pages there
chair of written text i haven't read it
word for word i've summarized in there
so you won't find word for word what
i've just said but all of those points
are within that section and then that
leads us to the recommendations so the
the recommendations in the report share
are that members consider the notice of
motion in cognizance of the four bullet
points so the previous resolution the
transfer should seek to maximize its
income streams wherever possible in
light of the financial impact of COBIT
19 on its financial position its fits
with the counselors climate emergency
declaration its carbon management plan
the equality and fairness of its
proposals for all residents and any
perceived benefits that the proposal
might have for the trading environment
at the time centers so again that's a
that's a judgment for councillors to
make the second recommendation is that
members result a result to approve or
reject the notice of motion and then
there is a third recommendation that
members consider any alternative
proposals and i know there's someone
actually made in the public
contributions that should be referred
back to full council for consideration
and if approved a full report be
presented to a subsequent meeting of the
community resources committee one other
thing to add is that coincidentally
we're also petitioned for two months
free parking and the results of this
discussion will be sent to the
petitioner they seem to point us to have
the same debate twice thank you
okay thank you Psalm we got those two
members wishing to speak will start with
Chancellor Hutchings and so I will
declare an interest am i doing a
business in holes worthy however my
business is currently closed I just sort
of said I don't particularly agree with
full car parking being completely free
as some of the public comments that I
think this will encourage the public
generally to park in those areas rather
than shoppers which I don't think will
help the traders and I would like to
make a proposal I don't know how this
particularly works but I would like to
make proposal that we were to look at
two hours free parking in the main towns
be hos worthy Biddeford and Torrington
obviously must reduce the ribbon on the
council but would I believe that would
support the businesses rather than just
make it completely free for all which
would lose a lot of income as I agree
there are anything longer than that so
whole day's parking wouldn't really help
the business so I like to make proposal
that we actually look at two hours free
parking into three main towns that is
interesting is there a second to that
proposal which I assume well first of
all I suppose we should ask Jensen and
McGough to formally propose and find a
seconder
but mr. chairman thank you much
and I like point of clarity so what
accounts is here at the moment listening
to this I did ask for the option of this
we brought forward underneath three
recommendations now when we've done the
1610 proposes in the past you had
different recommendations it's come
fruit before the councillors but but
this one here there's no different
options so it's being closed it's closed
cut really
now council councillor hutchins is
motion of the eye I can see them I've
had plenty of chats with plenty
councillors and a financial burden
that's actually on this issue itself now
you've got to think the two hours for
eat one or two hour free free parking is
that for the duration of our term in
office or is this is for two months
because if it's just for two months and
you know I wouldn't be sport just for
two months I'll be sport for the
duration but it's open-ended the motion
that's before you actually reads a
couple of different ways isn't it so if
this is councillor hutchins but it's
really duration I would support that for
the duration of the term and office of
TBC ok councillor hutchins come back to
at least yep come back introductions and
I mean I would be happy where we are I
mean I'll be happy to say if it was for
the next right I would like to see that
continue forever but maybe if we were to
if we were to agree to say six months
start which would then give us time to
actually review the whole the whole
situation out on the impact of free
parking for a limited time as in the
number of hours so that there was one
question I just wanted to ask Sean was
was about the actual ticket machines
previously when we've queried free
parking for a short period we've been
told that it wasn't possible but
obviously last year with you before we
had new machines fitted so I just wanted
to double-check that that was quite
feasible for it to be done or easy for
it to be done to produce free tickets
for an hour or two hours
yeah I I can't honestly say at the
moment I'd have to go and look into that
I can't really councillor hutchins and I
guess if there is an alternative
proposal that comes in under the third
recommendation of the report where I
guess it would need to be referred back
to a committee for all of this sort of
we need to look at the financial impacts
and the logistical feasibility of it all
anyway so yeah I could pick up on that
then right okay I just they just come in
quickly then yeah I'm sure so what what
Sean saying is what kind of councillor
hutchins proposed and what comes lemma
Goff
seems to be kind of supporting or
requesting and viewer different options
that would need to go back to full
council to change the notice of motion
so the notice of motion has and the the
report has been the reports been
prepared in line with a notice of motion
that was approved by a full council
which is why the reports been paid on
that basis so if if there's a a motion
to change that that would need to go
back to full council for members to
consider whether they wish to explore
something different so members couldn't
agree to those proposals today would
have to go back to full council to first
consider whether they wish to change the
notice of motion to look at something
different and then a report prepared on
that basis so in a nutshell it's council
McGough proposal or nothing
that's right chair and through the chair
good night yes can I ask why then I mean
we're talking about something that we
can agree as a the number of counts to
say it 10 councillors could agree today
to spend a hunt or to lose 192 thousand
pounds worth of income we can agree that
today but we couldn't agree to something
which would be far far less and you know
I would suspect you know 10 20 thousand
as opposed to hundred nine thousand
so we can't agree that but we can agree
a hundred ninety two thousand that just
doesn't seem to make sense
cherish lay just come back respond to
outlet J I think I think any proposal
today if that motion is approved by
members DNR would require a
recommendation to fund that at full
council because as David Haye is your
chief Finance Officer reported only two
weeks ago the council's budget is
currently overspent so any change to the
budget would need a report under a
recommendation back to full council to
change it so CNR may make a
recommendation today to accept this
motion which will need a full council
approval to change the budget to do so
so whatever we decide today has got to
go to full council anyway chair that's
that's right because you haven't got the
budget and to finance and the proposal
okay right cancel Hutchings can are you
happy for them or accept it for the
moment I'd move on to others I've got
eight wanting to speak it's Jeff right
we move on now to councillor Jones mix
from my list thank you Jeff I would like
to say if I started that I agree with
customer Hutchins and I think two hours
would potentially be a much more
sensible way to go I'm gonna leave you a
lot of the problems which have already
been alluded to regarding the cost and
obviously the fact that this would be us
obviously a much smaller hit to the
budget but obviously there would still
be a cost involved could we not seek to
cover that cost by raising or altering
the other parking tariffs so to increase
the parking tariffs for hours three and
four to cover that so then we wouldn't
have to change the budget I don't know
if that's feasible I think also there is
something
as we're sort of sitting through this
issue here there is something
constitutionally wrong that we're going
to have to play this this ping-pong back
and forth between committees and I think
that we need it's a shame that the
constitutional working group as I
understand it is now over because this
is something we should be should have
looked at to be able to streamline it
and to present prevent this sort of
thing happening again
I personally I'm a bit disappointed with
this all because I think there seems to
be a negativity coming from our leading
team I personally would support our
businesses however we can and I think we
almost seem to have a have a great deal
of inertia within within our within our
council as we have very little ability
to actually do anything when it comes to
covert in our response but the warden
one or two things we have been able to
do we've we've not we've not gone on and
done with them done them we've been
reactive rather than proactive we've
been given the green light from the
government and we've stored at the
traffic lights
it just seems a real shame to me I don't
agree with the report we've been given I
think there are a number of states which
either perhaps contradictory or maybe
maybe even more so I mean there's a
claim that there's been no research into
the effect of free car parking I mean I
looked into this it took me two minutes
and I found that the Vale of Whitehorse
District Council introduced two hours
free car parking and measured the
effects of this while I understand that
this isn't like for like as obviously we
are in a very different time at the
moment I think there was enough here to
draw a general comparison like seeing
that they're looking at market towns of
roughly a similar size and the
conclusion of that report was that if
which was done over several years that
if free car parking was removed we would
see it they would see a ten percent
decrease in revenue on the high street
so I wonder whether it would take
bearing that in mind that it would
actually have a positive impact I mean
in holes we do to the cowbird
restrictions we've had a reduction in
the amount of free car parking in the
square as the square was being shut on
Wednesdays to allow for the for the
market so businesses in the town were
finding that things were quieter than
they once were and obviously when it
comes to short-term parking just to pop
in and get something people will be
deterred by paying a small
be the idea as well that nobody else in
Devon has extended the free parking I
agree with Councilman Goff here entirely
why we don't necessarily have to follow
the others and also I mean I looked into
this after after being informed by other
cats Louie and it comes up that Dudley
counsel who I understand would be
something equivalent to Plymouth City
Council they've extended their free car
parking until August so and I understand
it is it could extend again so I think
that there are there are actually more
things going on than we than we realize
and abouts we should be looking into it
I was rather disappointed with councilor
Hudson's remarks regarding Westwood
Hoenn that because this doesn't include
the seaside resorts that we shouldn't be
able to do something benefit in
Torrington that I was just ludicrous she
seems to almost seems to be a
contradiction where as at the start of
the report it says that tourists won't
be put off by paying car parking and
then council Holsten seems to be
suggesting that are we need to have
Westwood hone in on in on the act as
well but it rate to me that if if we're
going to have a shortfall and as the
report tells us that tourists aren't
going to be effective my car parking
will pay whatever the price
why don't we then raise the raise the
price and west with hope arts and cover
it that way I think that we need to be
sort of working together on this and I
think that the fact that we won't do
something for these three towns despites
but just because it doesn't affect
another area is is wrong voted to
support the slipway and westward ho and
I know for the people in my ward in
holes with me there they're unlikely to
see much of a tourism benefit from that
and most people in the holes that you
would never go never go to Westwood Howe
anyway they go to view because it's ten
minutes down the road so no I find I
find that whole line of argument just
completely ridiculous so I my view I
think we should be looking out and if we
can get this one or two hours of free
car parking investigated and go with
that and we need to get on with its
sharp edge otherwise we're going to fall
behind thank you Joe
by Councillor Bushby
thank you
it's very interesting debate you know to
listen to but I think either way you'll
please sample it some people you want
please others clearly I just like to say
last Tuesday I spent all day delivering
over a hundred leaflets to the local
traders in a room of the town center of
Biddeford encouraging them to apply for
some cool grid related funding towards
provided to the town council and it was
interesting just talking to those
traders how the the reputation of Torah
sister cursor over the lat over this
period you know has risen dramatically
it was pointed out to me that you know
the those that were fortunate to be able
to apply to get the in Elite the 10,000
land grant that the government funded
you know for for the ones that are in
receipt of them you know rates that
these are that they you know they were
really really appreciative of the fact
that Tory's got 98% of the grants paid
in such a short space of time and it
just seems to me that we've you know
we've got an ideal opportunity here you
know rather looking looking upon this in
the negative of what it's going to cost
Horace it's a present
Furion lost revenue but what it could do
to tourists this okay so in terms of
rebuilding that relationship with the
local traders who always think that are
hard done by you've got an opportunity
here you know to support them by giving
them another two months of free car
parking in the main car parks a bit of
rhetoric and hoesley and you know that
we could one hell of a way of restoring
trust you know this partnership really
and working that we you know we're
continually striving to do with with the
local traders it seems to me almost like
a golden opportunity so you know I I
don't want to muddy the issue by
proposing anything other than what kind
of a golfers
I think the motion is quite clear that
it doesn't need anything else
it just needs you know a simple vote
hopefully it wins and then it can get
back to be ratified by full council I
would however like to just pick up a
couple of points on the conclusions in
the report the last paragraph in the
sorry the last line in the first
paragraph it states perhaps the missing
component for trading success for
trading success there's a retail and
leisure offer that is commensurate with
the current charging regime not condom
sexual what that means but then in the
next paragraph it says it could be the
Biddeford torrent in a hos worthy would
see greater benefit if the focus were on
lifting a quality of the retail measure
offer of the time to meet the quality
expectations associated with lube
parking charges rather than reducing the
parking charges in a race to the bottom
now if I was one of the traders in any
of those times and reading I would take
that as a almost a bit of a sir it's
said to me it's a bit of a condescending
comment to make in a conclusion that is
going to be made public so I'm really
surprised that that was there but as I
said probably said enough on that at the
moment but some I am going to propose
I'm gonna second and comes from the Goss
notice of motion and before thank you
thank you
councillor Cottle hat hanging next to
not a member of the committee I would
like to express my support the notes
motion in order to help our town centres
we need to be doing everything we can to
encourage people to support their local
traders and to feel safe doing so a
number of councils across the country
are extending free parking in some point
way as a temporary measure in efforts
the best football
and help businesses get back on their
feet a quick google search shows that
this is happening in little Hampton
where'll Mansfield and over Dudley Selby
Burnley East Indy and Stroud to name a
few free parking would attract people to
shop locally in their town centers
rather than heading to the supermarkets
where parking is free it would allow
people more time to shop and this extra
time is now needed while customers are
needing to queue outside of shots in
order to appear to government guidelines
I understand concerns over loss of
revenue for the council but as a council
we also need to show support to our
local traders this motion is not for all
car parts in torij but is specifically
to help those in the town centers since
reading the financial reports and having
spoken to some of the traders in great
Taunton I would like to suggest two
hours free parking
rather than 24-hour this would have less
of an impact on the council's resources
and with not effects the issue with
regard to parking permits either if
today's decision still needs to be
ratified by full council before it can
be implemented then I see no reason why
further report could not be undertaken
to include different options for both
one and two hours of free parking and a
final decision could then be made by all
councillors after full council meeting
many retailers have been shut for months
and this would give them a helping hands
and protect jobs we need to get behind
our retailers after what has been a
devastating hits their income during the
lockdown an element of free parking will
also come promote crisps further and
payment Cameron's new marketing campaign
from torch District Council the shop
local and shot say it would show a real
commitment from the council to our town
centres and the local economy and it
could be the difference between whether
some traders come out to the other side
of this or not thank you
thank you now Chancellor Britain
okay hear me yes okay me well I support
councillor McGough is opposing in
principle but I do feel that we could
improve on this and do do it better
firstly I think that the next two months
are likely to be the busiest times in
torij August and September and really
you know why should we be giving a sort
of reduced amount for visitors I mean
it's our busiest months I don't think I
think you'd be premature to bring it in
then if we surely make more sense to
have a concessionary car parking
reduction during the months of October
November and up to December which then
tie in with its Frank a bit of a trend
Council who who also do a subsidised
free car parking during the weekends of
December that would mean that we
wouldn't miss out on the sort of main
tourist months the same time we could be
looking to our businesses who will
probably buy that time will have settled
tenders at the moment people aren't
really coming out very much you know the
pattern hasn't been set you're on how
people are going to shop only that we
need to if we're going to do this we
need to publicize it well so that
everybody will know that they're getting
a some free car parking and clearly from
two previous speakers a to our free park
our car parking makes more sense and
bring here all day one the other thing
is of course the argument goes that not
everybody has a car and therefore would
not benefit from it but if our town
centres don't thrive and don't survive
then people without cars are going to
suffer just as much because they won't
have that convenience in their towns
because you know big majority of the
people do live in towns won't have that
facility if you look at what happened
during the lockdown period for example
and a benefit for example the people who
are coming into
we're coming in to the banks and the
post office they are sort of the key
attraction to get people into town they
they have to do this so if we've got a
better car parking concession than it
would mean that they would do in the
future stay in actually looking around
our shops and purchase and buy we hope
so as I say we would need it would need
a further report and it is a shame that
our our sort of system if you like of
the Constitution doesn't allow for
instant decisions to be made especially
over something as expensive as this but
nonetheless we should try to get it
right and to benefit everybody in our
community thank you
Thank You councillor Locke yeah just to
pick up on one or two points already
made I do agree without the friends and
I was gonna suggest prat something on
the same nines why not delay this free
parking until October November to
December when more shots will be open
more people will be around and hopefully
we might even know the result of the
future of high streets bidding so that
would encourage more people to come out
at Christmas I think all the time we
compare as those or other areas of the
country I think we're just completely
muddy in the waters because nothing you
know we just got to concentrate on
taurage what we know about storage it
doesn't matter what happens at little
Hampton or anything on the Saturday I
did a little exercise I drove into
Torrington I got there us twos out of
the afternoon and there were five shops
open in the whole of Torrington only
five shops so I then drove to Biddeford
High Street drove up the High Street
there are obviously more shots over
because there are more shops but there
was plenty of car parking space in the
designated phase at the high street and
though I speak wasn't very busy at all I
then drove down into Westford home and I
could not believe how busy Westford Howe
was it was absolutely heaving I saw no
evidence of any social distance
and the only person I saw with the mask
on was one old man who got off the bus
that's by the bar with the cardiology
maybe because again why I think the
delay the free parking because you know
over the years I've spoken to many
holidaymakers and they think parking in
torij is so cheap compared to other
places where they live so I do think we
will be missing a trick if we don't
maintain the car park in charge during
the summer months but I agree the counts
of Renton introduced and later time in
the year thank you very much right now
we'll come sort of a golf again
thank you much mr. chairman
you remember it I actually spoke to you
myself mr. chairman and Steve first and
Shawn Carney and I you know preempted
what was gonna be happiness evening I
did ask for the option because you read
the motor says free parking
they didn't say all day free parking
it's actually left open-ended so you
actually make it you want but there
should have been options for the counter
service and because of the finance katsu
shipping options to make this you know
more plausible received and really and
I'm not gonna retract emotion at all
emotion stands our traders need this
help with immediate effect
now it may come a receipt a loss to TDC
finances but we're not making a loss we
just made a loss of 1.7 million to a
court case out of public where that much
money's gone down and we all made the
loss as a council I'm not putting blame
on anybody we all take the day to
Bruntlett smear but this is one of the
main reasons why we're in a financially
it's a situation that we are now chapel
project program what I need to touch mr.
council is because is very important
this doesn't need to wait to September
this needs to come through as soon as
possible so we can start moving our
money around like the money there is the
public's money and is supposed to
benefit the public that to me we got a
perfect opportunity now to help our
traders who actually help your local
economy thrive again now that's on
counter locks point that by the high
street funding well not only benefits
biddeford it doesn't benefit
homes worthy it doesn't benefit Sorensen
it doesn't benefit West Widow doesn't
benefit your rural wards now I'm a bit
of a gang style I see much I can come I
want to see a bit of to thrive but being
fair across the board this wouldn't the
High Street funding bid it doesn't
really affect many of the places and
torrid so you know that's not really a
point and and I got such a bike waiting
you know wait in couple of months you
know the traders need I hope now if it's
no Disney and I hope and when nine
hundred ninety two thousand paying we're
pretty quick to sign off when we go over
budget when we deliver projects ourself
we're pretty happy to sign off whatever
the budget is and we all go although it
needs to be done that's good it's spent
it's because we're not actually spending
our own money if we had under night to
your phone's been in the bank no I would
do it it's an investment I'm invested
into the area we're vesting back to our
traders who best to us so it's me this
is a no-brainer
and we've counteractions point of
raising the two hours free parking now I
think the best thing to do is Fortis
motion this afternoon here now get it
forwards we get implemented straight
away to actually benefit for the area
now and council actions can then bring
forward ease motion again which would
then address it for one or two hours
free par configuration of the their term
of office thank you much
right councillor bright Thank You chair
I let me know interest property opposite
one of the car parks in Torrington well
let's see expansion to the word and it's
used for councillor motion
giving it more options available more
changes so one hour or two hours of free
parking or that one car park is free in
each of the villages or towns or that we
actually have a look at the permanent
charges that we do on a day to day
whether that's the time to change it
maybe I should all be considered at once
I don't know
let's support the council and Brenton
said we must advertise this we don't
really sing our praises enough so we do
need to make sure that as well
advertised
but one of the most common things I get
when I speak into residents is that they
say the the drive to Sainsbury's as the
coop yeah oh you know tax goes wherever
and they can park there for free it's
like two hours free parking or all day
sometimes and they can in one place well
you can do the same in baby food in
Torrington assuming you know you can go
you get stuff from different shops and
you can't because it's part you got paid
charges people don't want to do it you
know they go straight to the easy answer
and do it all that very much changes the
parking challenges indeed right Sean
would you like to come back at this
stage please thank you I just want to
just pick up on a couple of the comments
that the councillors have made I suppose
the first thing to understand with the
parking charges is that we run our part
in charges in accordance with the
off-street parking places order now you
know obviously members considering and
decide upon what is an appropriate
charge we then have to place an advert
in the paper and go through a process of
having that the order changed so there
is a bit of a time delay there and
that's for permanent charges if you want
to simply stop enforcement like we did
on during lockdown that's a different
arrangement we simply stop our
enforcement activities if we're amending
charges there's a process to follow so
that's the first point to note there
second point was a point of cancer Jones
as though we haven't been doing much to
support our residents to Cove it I think
I would say that actually I think is a
small Authority we've been doing a
remarkable amount to support our
communities through lock down as a
district council which it will be very
proud of what we've achieved and what we
continue to do for our communities and
then to come back to council to push
beyond this point about that they
perhaps the experience that people are
getting in town centres if that
statement in the report wasn't meant as
a slight to individual businesses is
simply a cravat
a comment to provoke debates when you
look at research on this
it basically says if you are going
towards an experience that you value
really highly or that is a really high
quality you will pay an extraordinary
amount of car parking fees to experience
that now the question is do people value
the sound centers that we have enough
and should we be trying to help them to
create a better experience and that's
what we've been doing with our future
heydrich but that's what our open up
work it's all about and all this is
stuff that we are very very actively
involved in as you and as you are as
Ward members you know you're driving the
agenda office so again you must come to
the conclusions you wish to in in terms
of the free parking but those are just a
couple of points of clarity in there
thank you okay Thank You Chancellor
Christie Thank You mr. chairman um I'm
gonna start by playing devil's advocate
in a way because there are certain
problems and certain issues I haven't
been raised here I'm saying that the
motion is incredibly vague a lot of
councils have picked up on this is it
all day
is it one hour is it two hours having
such a vague motion doesn't help if you
are going to go for all-day it has been
tried once before
and the Chamber of Commerce actually
asked for and Tory did do it and even
the Chamber of Commerce had to omit that
all the car parks were full by 8:45 in
the morning with partly their own
members and partly office workers and
that's a real problem you're gonna face
it it was all day secondly um I keep
hearing free car parking there's no such
thing as free car parking would have
already heard about the one at Westwood
ho where mr. Braddock pays for it we all
know the suit Marcus actually add on a
cost for running their own car parks
it's not free and as such there is a
cost to tourists District Council of
course and firstly the loss of our car
parking charges if you may
there's also the cost of the attendance
because if you make it two hours
somebody's gonna have to please sir and
the attendants have to be paid
you've got maintenance costs of the
carpark you've also got the business
rates which nobody has pointed out yet
the torch has to actually pay business
rates on its own car parks and we get
very very little of that back it would
be nice if the government of copper
covered all our exceptional costs of
meeting code of it but they're not so
torrid he's actually losing quite a lot
of money my third point I'm slightly
surprised that nobody from benefit and
written in all came from Torrington
which is slightly odd then the motion
doesn't apply to Appledore or Westwood
Hubbell and we see I'll seem unfair if
we are going to vote for it but there is
a greater issue than unfairness here
because storages income is gonna have to
be raised from somewhere and it will be
probably spread across everyone we're
all paid perhaps extra council tax I
don't know how are we going to keep our
services running if we ain't got the
income if it does go right across our
population you're gonna have a situation
where those without cars are subsidizing
those with cars offering them free car
parking now I just checked my ward
profile in the 2011 census one third of
the households in my ward which is
benefit have no car so here we are
saying alright that third good got
subsidized done two thirds who are much
better off there is odd now I've
listened to all the arguments there's
some really good points made here and
I'm afraid I agree with councillor
Brenton and councillor Locke this is the
wrong time to bring it in because if
you've been going around the car parks
in the last week last couple of weeks
they're not full people are still
staying at home they are still very host
to come into our car parking and the
people that are coming and the people
I've talked to or at least are seen
around the town a lot of the motorists
and I've been talking to some
shopkeepers and they're saying there are
quite a few tourists around and it does
seem the wrong time of year to do this
and I think council brenton accounts a
lot of hit on the right solution here
that yes free car parking after the main
season is over I realize that we can't
do that because of the motion but that's
what I would go for thank you
don't fear laws thank you Thank You
chair sorry about that
I'm sure these are very strange times
indeed this notice of motion and first
up ranks many driven by this horrible
pandemic desires to help those traveling
into our towns and help the shopkeepers
and businesses there in considering this
my mind went back there's some wise
words I received when I first became a
member of this council back in the 90s
but then chief executive when richard
Brazelton said you're not just a
Westwood home counselor you are now a
tourist district councillor you now
represent residents of the whole
district and you will oversee the work
of well-being in viscounts two weeks ago
we listened to a financial report the
like of which none of us could ever
imagine we would witness the fabric and
well-being of many District Council's
crumbling around us prudent management
compared with many sees us on safer
ground but how many more body rows can
we sustain this council relies on its
income to provide its services this
motion takes away in income stream
however well-meaning this motion is we
cannot let our Council our employees and
officers down and put our council at
further risk by forgoing income that we
really haven't got to give away Thank
You chair then to counselor Hutchings
thank you Jeff um so I'm just to come
back on several point from several
councillors really but I think what the
discussion here is proved to me that our
three towns that we're talking about are
all very different um you know you talk
about visitors holes are they does not
rely on visitors in the summer yes we
get a few but we are not dependent we do
not have a massive influx so when you're
all talking about visitors paying we
don't have that we don't have that
luxury in our town if you look at our
charges they're not they're not hugely
increased through the summer months but
we aren't talking about that we aren't
talking and holes worthy I'm not
fighting for this for tourists I'm
fighting it to get people that live
around holes worthy coming in to support
our traders so yes they have the option
of coming in and just an hour two hours
free parking to go into our town and
spend their money Shawn you said about
upping the game hoes are they is a
typical rural town center in fact most
will argue it's a village center for a
modern from our numbers but we are a
town and so it's not about massive
impact of toilet it's about just giving
those little local people the
encouragement to drive into our town
rather than drive to a supermarket and
dermis already said about the high
street fund that doesn't affect holes
worthy or Torrington council is Bushby
you said about making it free all day
but in holes worthy we have two public
car parks one of them is slap-bang in
the middle of our town if we make that
free parking all day we will have the
issue of local people parking in there
all day for free and that's not what
we're trying to do we're trying to
encourage short stays of people from
outside coming in to spend money in the
town and I've touched on that on the
visitors
now the question you said about the fact
that was losing money but the problem is
if we don't support our local traders
now we are going to have some of these
shops here so long term we're going to
lose taxes anyway because they are going
to be paying any business rates in the
future because those businesses won't be
here which is why I think we need to
support them now and then we talked
about areas you know benefitting and
others not well the slipway and Westwood
home does not help anyone in wholes
worthy I'm not saying it's a bad thing
but you didn't hear me saying why should
we spend a million pound on westward ho
and not in Ho's worthy it's something
that's needed doing in our in our
district so I think we have to be you
know whatever we do will help some and
not others so to try and to try and say
about Carla's not car or things like
that I don't think that's what it's
about
it's about just supporting the
businesses in our towns you know I put
forward my emotion again if somebody
would second it that we give two hours
free car parking for six months in three
main in the three main towns that would
be down to those counselors from those
towns to decide exactly what their car
parks are I have one particular car park
that I think will benefit our town maybe
Jeff I would second that motion Jer yeah
can I just come in please yes just gonna
clarify the point on notices of motion
because I know there's been a lot of
discussion here today about amending
them in the notice of motion under our
Constitution are submitted to full
council and they can be amended when
they have to be amended at full council
the reason being is one it's full
council that decide if they're going to
allow that motion to go forward and then
it's the Constitution that decides where
that notice of motion will proceed to so
on this occasion its CNR because CNR
have delegated powers from full council
to deal with land and property issues so
it's the 36 members give or take a
couple members a vote at full council
that agreed for this motion in this
format to go forward to see and are
now it would all be fine and well if
that if the mate is a member that
proposed motion was on the next
committee and and on this occasion he is
but if you will remember that put
forward a notice of motion to full
council only to then discover that
another had been changed by another
committee you may not be too happy about
that and that's the reason for it so if
you wanted to remember motion it should
have been done at full council then from
the officer perspective when that notice
of motion has been approved and moved on
to the next committee you then have an
officer report prepared on the basis of
that notice of motion which gives you
all the facts and figures available to
you to enable you to make an informed
decision
the difficulty with trying to amend it
today is you're stabbing in the dark
because we don't have the full facts and
information I mean we can guess that it
may be maybe less I don't know and I
don't know about the car parking charges
and how much it would or wouldn't cost
us and that's a difficulty and then in
addition you've got full council that
they've approved to one notice of motion
they haven't approved an amendment so
unfortunately today we are stuck with
the amendment that was put forward by
councillor McGrath at full council and
to propose an amendment it would have to
go back to full council now the only
reason on this basis that this one has
to go back to full council is because it
affects the council's budget so under
normal circumstances if it wasn't
affecting the budget the members could
make a decision tear in now and the
difficulty is because it affects the
budget that's a decision that full
council has to make so it would have to
go back to full council for the
budgetary impact can I ask you a
question but the point of order chair
point of order I'd like the race yes
yeah so is saying that if this notice of
motion was approved and it went back to
full council amendments could be made to
it at full council is that correct yeah
you can put forward
amendments at full council and full
council can approve or not approve the
amendment but if it can't be done here
unfortunate that's correct constant
brenton though that is the way forward
for those people who are talking about a
two-hour thing or changing the actual
months etc then if it was approved now
you could go back to full council and
these amendments could be put forward
and voted on absolutely thank you
point of order chair yeah could we not
make not make an amendment but make a
recommendation there sorry the CNR
committee make a recommendation to have
a further report into more detail of
what the parking charges would be rather
than proposing an amendment at this
stage no because then you're amending
can't some aghast notice of motion so
you can put forward and never notice of
motion at full council for that to be
done councillor Jones but that would
have to go back to CNR again to make
that decision if they agreed with that
notice of motion like I said the only
reason this needs to get back to full
council was because of the budget but
this current notice of motion could have
been amended but it had to have been
amended at full council and what
happened was it was proposed and
seconded and approved you're going to
see an R and that's why we're stuck with
just this notice of motion so we can't
make amendments today right now I got
several wanting to speak
Chancellor leather long committee member
Thank You chair I was just amoled a job
with me yeah mousing amusing myself
what's been interested to listen to
what's been said I've always had an
issue with the hours that we charge for
parking anyway because I think from 8:00
in the morning till 6:00 o'clock him
even is far too long
and I do think we can knock two hours
off and I would knock two hours off at
the end of the day so I would stop
charging at four o'clock and that would
still give opportunity for people to
shop after four o'clock not to say
there's a lot of businesses still aren't
open in the main towns even now and as
has been made a point of a lot of people
have been cowed into staying omen and
don't even want to come out of the house
but I do think we can knock two hours
off we can't amend this I've never known
a notice of motion that cannot be
amended but as stasis said an amendment
made now we'll go back to full counsel
with the figures needed so if the
amendment was to not two hours off our
parking at the end of the period at four
o'clock finished charging at four
o'clock that amendment could go to full
council and that cost would be put to
full council then have knock in the two
hours off across all our car parks not
just the main ones in the town but you
know the points been made that some
businesses don't help themselves some of
them don't not as bad as it used to be
but I think some still recognize half
day closing in biddeford not as many as
used to but some do and I can't
understand that certainly not in a
holiday area and certainly not in a
summer period but I do mean our hours
are too long and I think if you made it
at the start of the day if you if you
said well we won't start charging till
10 o'clock that would then encourage
people to park overnight and leave it
there until 10 o'clock in the morning
whereas if they've got to get out and
move it before 8 o'clock they're not
like to leave it there all night
fair point made by councillor Christina
you know the one we've gotten out of the
pill carpark on a Saturday midday you
can't get
after ten past twelve it's full of
residents parking in the main but I do
think the hours that we do charge was
too long and we should be making the
gesture to support our businesses
throughout the district so you know if
somebody wanted to better make that
recommendation that four o'clock is when
we finished challenging on all our car
bombs
thanks chef councillor bursaries thank
you then councillor the Gulf's notice of
motion simply reads we can help towards
this by continuing free parking for two
months
just consider McGough not have the right
to add two or three hours at this stage
particularly as by adding a time limit
of two or three hours would be a
significant saving on what origin are
suggesting that they would lose in
overall income McGough should come in at
this point thank you very much mr.
chairman
I just like the rewind about 20 minutes
to go and that's accounts that bushmeat
I asked for this option Kazik push fee
to come forward as a as an option on the
agenda report of one hour and to air
free parking and I was told I couldn't
do that yes I was trying I'm trying to
be proactively turn out the busy
rhetoric it's quite easy for some people
just you know to run a motion down but
least I've got the boss but a motion
forward to try and haven't people now
we've got 36 was on there and we're all
bright cookies on it and we'll represent
the public got to do the best for your
own interest but I ask this have seen
their offices and I even asked a chair
as well but it's option to go forward
and it was ignored as an option when we
do options other recommendations and
motions going forward you get these
options why wasn't we giving this option
they obviously any any of them any of
you know we just say known about the e2
hours free parking
yes I'd happily sports our eyes free
parking I want to try and give something
back to the businesses out you know the
business is in Taurus the whole you know
what a storage but the time centres
mainly because it's time
censors where the decoration is we
struggle you know economically we're
struggling in town centers we need to
try and revive these coastal areas as in
a pad or we all know as a pad or most of
these places a second homeless and
there's a lot of money thing happens a
lot of money in Westford oh and it's all
tourism based all these holiday camps in
Western Oh South Bay Braddock's camps
they're all full
westward living there full again it's
lovely to see it it should be full but
this is money coming in the area to give
free parking on new coastal resorts it's
just pure madness because the turnover
people coming in daily journey it's a
great revenue and that was touched on
the fact that the borough's produces a
good revenue I'm just simply trying to
give the business owners you know the
businesses in torrid a helping hand Rico
would none of us ever gone for Coke had
fallen her life and is economically has
been a disaster for everybody myself
included in the business owner but this
doesn't benefit me a slightest I
understand the business you know so I
don't get no benefit from this the
benefit is try and help the people were
in torij but I need to rather than a
point of there was a I think I can wait
two or three days after motion went
forward there's a petition handed in to
TDC which missed I think by better day
but I think the petition support was 500
local people have benefit now I take my
hat off to the person you've got to go
out together and actually add the
backbone to put his petition forward I'm
just so sorry I didn't come forward at
the same time to come inside motion
forward but a coincided pretty good
because it's two months exactly what I
perfect with so you know you've got
someone at least think exactly the same
count for no mark
yeah I mean listening to what everyone
is gone
come here you cannot you muted yeah
thank you listening to all the various
suggestions going forward to hours a
year to ELLs there would it not be
easier for all concerned
every if we rejected the motion as it
stands and someone but the new motion in
ASAP say tomorrow proposing two hours
free carpark is that we've got a real
substantive motion and then that will
give the officers time to prepare any
necessary reports which all it will be
easier to reject this motion as it
stands and get in tomorrow with a fresh
idea so that one stirs can find out all
the information mmm counselor Newton
yeah thank you interesting debate I'd
just like to say that I'm
I fear that traders if this was enacted
and if these measures went through I
think traders would probably be
disappointed in the outcome because I
think as has been said many times that
the lack of footfall at the moment is
more through people being cautious about
venturing out than it is being put off
by any parking cost I didn't actually
think that people really consider that
strongly the cost of parking I think
it's more that there are health issues
at and and people are concerned about
not going out and if you look at
comments coming from elsewhere in the
country you look at football in in
center of London for instance where
parking isn't an issue there and yet the
football is right down as well so I
don't think it's solely a cost issue
that frightening people off they would
like to think it is but I fear that they
may be disappointed because there's a
lot of indications that many many people
in fact
don't have the confidence at the moment
to be going out in mixing properly in
the public or in the shopping areas etc
that's my coin thank you Thank You
councillor hutchins again nej just to
come back to Stacey and you said that
the the different chart or the cost
different costs couldn't be done is
there a reason for that because I
thought when we agree to have these new
machines put in that it was the reason
they were they were super duper machines
one of the reason was that we could have
an easy breakdown of different in
different charges so with Dermott's
motion which says free parking it
doesn't specify what that free parking
would be so it doesn't say free parking
seven days a week it just says free
parking so if he was to say that that
was for say two hours and agreed to that
he would have to greet on his motion but
is that not something we could then vote
on here it should be or should we
correct
I think sure that's gonna come in and
Shaun's more a favor of the car parking
charges than I am sorry that was
probably a bad example on my part I was
just trying to explain the reason behind
the notice of motion and what our
Constitution says and I I understand
that members find it frustrating and you
know even to a certain perspective
officers do we doing our best to try and
facilitate as much as possible and
councillor McGough you're absolutely
correct you did ask these questions and
we did answer and and unfortunately our
Constitution states how many submissions
have to be del where you put forward
these this notice of motion and Shaun
has prepared the report on that basis
and I was just trying to explain from a
members perspective if another committee
changed your notice of motion you might
not be too happy about that going
forward and that's predominantly the
reason why it is noticed as a motion are
sanctioned by full council to go forward
to the relevant committee to debate but
I'll let Shaun come in on the car
parking and the car parking machines
because that's definitely not my airway
or so
yeah so so to come back to councillor
hutchins yes we could do that that's
perfectly possible if we were asked to
prepare a report which talked about two
hours free parking or not not charging
after 4:00 p.m. we have all of that data
to to give you the numbers to consider
so the last time we looked at it as in
this is probably three four years ago
now the last time we looked at a two
hours free that was about its sixties
but about two thirds or nearly three
quarters of your peer pain display
income was derived in the first two
hours of parking now that that ranges in
your tariffs so for yourself in homes
with E you have a well park one pound
all day which we wouldn't have counted
in that but we would have counted the
manor 30p for half an hour the sixty P
for our of 124 two so we can work all
that out we know how many transactions
we know what times a day we know what
days of the week there we are
councillor Brandon
muted oh there we go right okay Oh
cherry we could be here till midnight
doing this because there's obviously
lots of variations and options here but
clearly if members are minded to in
principle support this notice of motion
then like myself should vote for it now
and then when it goes to full council
all the amendments can be proposed and
seconded and voted on and that that way
we can arrive at a hopefully a
conclusion which suits most people
because in a moment we're obviously we
can't change this at all that's the
solicitors pointed out for for fairly
obvious reasons and no matter what we do
to our Constitution that particular
procedure will stay the same there is no
way of changing that unless we come
totally undemocratic so that that's the
way the system is I'm afraid in a
democracy so say we support councilman
coughs knows motion oh when it comes to
full council the the hours the timings
all that one by one and there will be my
pleasure and duty to go through them all
can be put forward and voted on either
proof or reject it and then we come to a
final conclusion which will then be the
view of the full council end of argument
point of Audigier yeah weren't that done
for Stacey them really would that there
and if there was an amendment made of
full council to say have the two hours
free car parking with that then need to
go back to seeing our and then back to
full council again or could that be
decided on the night and obviously if
there is talking about two hours free if
this is approved today as it stands and
goes back to full council will bearing
in like the discussion that's been had
in this committee will the two hours
free carpark can be put in a report to
the full council if that makes sense
thank you there's no amendments today no
amendments on this notice of motion no
no I agree Casterbridge I'm saying if
it's amended at the full council
I handed the full counsel to be able to
make the amendment and then approve it
or we'll have to go back to CNR and then
back to full counsel to adjust the
budget oh so you want me to come in yes
please like I think what comes Larry
Jones the same is right so first of all
full counsel would need to consider a
revised notice of motion so if that
something came back to the next four
cups or saying can we look at these
different options thus that's what would
be considered at full counsel then a
report would be prepared assuming those
that motion was approved to go to CNR to
consider the financial implications and
again dependent on the the cost which
obviously we haven't done would
determine whether or not and CNR could
change or a full council decision would
be required unfortunately I think that's
really the way the Constitution works
and Stacy adds anything if that's not
quite correct
Stacy any comment that's absolutely
correct sir if this motion was approved
tonight Spri CNR the current motion as
counselor McGuffy splitter that could go
ahead at full council but counselor
Jones you're absolutely correct if an
amendment to the emotion was proposed at
full council that amendment would have
to come back to CNR and then if it was
approved to have to go back to full
council because of the budget
implications and I can see cuts dojin's
you're shaking your head and I can
understand why but why you're frustrated
but hopefully my explanations gone some
way to try and explain why it is like
that round in circles councillor Newton
ladies and gentlemen I think we need
some agility here we are we are in in
absolutely unique times and what you're
trying to do is to trigger a further
officer report because without the
detail that comes in a further officer
of
then nobody can make a binding decision
on any new or any further proposal is it
not possible if you if you don't approve
it and I'm not remember the committee so
it's obviously for your say but if you
don't approve it today but you make
recommendations back to full council
will that not then trigger an officer
report which will allow a final decision
to be taken in film Council because
otherwise it's going to go on and
actually by the time the relief is
needed the time has passed
surely no no suggested that hmm you've
already chair I've got to go in a minute
but I will say this this notice of
motion before this committee tonight can
you can put an amendment to it you can
amendment to it but then go back to full
council with that amendment I've never
in any council is a notice of motion
that cannot be amended put forward that
you can't amend it so it can be amended
but the amendment then wanting to speak
first Thank You chair and I just want
some clarity because cards on the table
I know which were one of votes I want to
vote for two hours free car parking I
don't want to vote for all day free car
parking no two hours is going to make a
massive difference but I feel we should
enable something for the interim anyway
but I need to know what I vote for
tonight because I am not keen on voting
for a motion for all-day free car
parking which I actually don't agree
with so I could do some guidance please
on which way we go here for from the
point of view of what we vote on tonight
I think we've all established we need to
set respectful Council with an amended
motion where does that
leave us with this one please I looked
to the officers giant church like him in
so I'll see you've got the the notice of
motion in front of us for members of
Siddhartha consider tonight obviously we
have schedules and the chairs agreed to
an extraordinary fall council meeting on
the 27th of July so if a member and all
members were to put forward a separate
notice emotion contain in what they
wanted to be considered full council
would then consider the content of that
notice motion and so there needs to be
care taken in how that notice of motion
is worded because its members at full
council will then determine whether or
not a report comes back to see an hour
with that level of detail so it's is
crucial and critical to have the word in
accurate in the notice of motion because
that's what members at full council are
voting and ultimately instructing
officers to prepare a report based on so
if if members don't want to take this
particular notice motion forward tonight
they would vote against it and then
something substituted or new notice of
motion brought forward at the next full
council meeting hopefully that's clear
chair yes but we're going around in
circles councillor Locke
can you unmute rows right with me now
yes yeah I will reiterate them what I
said at least 20 minutes ago that this
motion is rejected tonight and count
some of God puts in another one ASAP
tomorrow and I think you know most of us
want to our screen for our committee put
some strong emotion in then that will
give the officers times of get the
necessary falls out for the next
emergency council meeting but I think
the only clear way forward is to reject
his motion tonight and counts in the
Gulf to put in a fresh motion tomorrow
oh my gosh you returned thanks
I mean I actually agree with Casey
Brinson you know his charity council and
you know is my emotion and I'm pretty
sure I can actually amend my own motion
and do many motion to going forward on
two hours free parking which is what I
said right from beginning cancer lock I
did racist officers but unfortunately
the option wasn't given for anyoneís
evening then this would remain things
would be more clarity that's not putting
officers there it's not gonna dig at
people the motion is what it is I tried
my best to try and improve the area and
to amend the motion this pretty no
sports in principle to go back to we're
still gonna be ratified by full counts
as a full council erupted decision and
decision obviously the general sent us
now is to has free parking I fully
support I just want to try and give the
community the best start we can give
something back and but we need to do its
part you know quick I I don't I don't
agree with kinds of Newton's thing about
people don't they it's just an
unfortunate thing about rural and urban
Ward's you know the urban wards is built
up and it's you know we got less money
in the other mort's and it that's
factual I'm not making things up but it
is actually factual it's in over there
you know demenna motion to bring it by
the full council for the two hours free
car parking I've fully you know endorses
a sports but not for four o'clock
onwards the working day and maybe finish
at 4 o'clock for time centers know we've
got to do some broad town centers so
yeah I'm one happy I guess Brenton you
know I go by your
and you know we get on personal level
and you know please leave with different
groups and makes their wards this this
is the benefit donor area and I totally
agree with you
it's amended the two hours free parking
to go back to Foulke and so there's no
really flashy report or motion a bit
forward catalogue it is what it says on
the tin Chancellor Bush great Thank You
Tara
well I'm convinced that councilman golf
must be allowed to amend this motion
note to put a number in Sophie Watts two
hours in there it's dead simple that
they gives the officer is enough time to
produce a report for the next full
council and then it can go through
hopefully on the note but what if you
put two hours down it's going to be
considerably less money loss the
tortoise at Council than all-day parking
so council on the golf should be allowed
now Amanda's notice of motion and add a
figure there thank you
care I move that we go to the vote I've
got others wanting to speak don't state
thank you the full council 36 counts of
both to descend this particular motion
to CNR which is 12 councilors those 12
councilors suddenly want to start
changing the motion we don't know what
the other 24 think and I keep hearing
that we can return it to the full
council and discuss the amendment set as
far as I know there's absolutely nowhere
on the full council where a motion can
be discussed it doesn't go back for
further amendments it will have to be a
new motion put forward simple as that
there is no there's never any item on
formal council where a decision that CNR
can be discussed it just never happened
so I don't know what people are talking
about so if it wants to go ahead and I
I've got no probably two hours free
parking but as I said I also agree new
accounts of crane to the council
knock it should be held off because I
can't I think councilman Newton picked
up on a point I made earlier that people
are not coming into towns at the moment
and do you think people who have been
locked down for three months because it
worries about their health they're gonna
think oh I can save 1 pound 20 and rush
into art it's not gonna happen so it
needs a new motion and we need to think
very carefully about the timing of it
thank you hey could I just come back
please yep
yes just just wondered on what console
Christy said he's absolutely right so it
would have to be a new notice of motion
at full council so you wouldn't have
noticed motion with a report at full
council it would be for the 36 members
at full council to consider a new notice
of motion and if that was approved then
that would be the basis of a report
taken to the next scene are so comes
loose can I guess raise a point of order
here that if it does if it counselor
the golf but it's in a new motion can we
suspend the Standing Orders at the next
full council and pass it there and then
so it doesn't have to go back and forth
on this ping-pong it's being done before
we've taken an emergency issue motion we
took the one from councillor Brenton
actually about the cattle market I think
we can do one at full council because as
Ben said we are living in very unusual
times and we need to react in perhaps by
the unusual ways Jay if I can respond no
it have to it would have to be passed as
a motion at full council and then a
report prepared should it should the
motion be approved in that guise then
you look at if if if it went to the next
full council ourselves the the 27th of
July the next CNR committee after that
unless the chair was minded to hold and
call an extraordinary CNR would be the
7th of September I would call an
extraordinary meeting
this account here whoever it is
counselor Brenton is the next one do
you
Thank You chair it's just well I think
I've already jumped the gun earlier on a
point of order about going to the boat
actually and because we couldn't run in
circles a little bit very much so
right mr. Hayes wishes to speak we
haven't heard from him so if any points
been answered by Steve I mean the reason
you couldn't vaulted the Nets full
council officer we'd have to do the
financial implications of any - I was
free parking as Sean's alluded to the
significant proportion of our parking
income is actually within the first two
hours so therefore obviously with the
report previously presented to CNR about
the financial implications of Kovach 19
we'd need some time as officers to get a
report together to actually show the
full impact to - I was free parking on
how the council would bridge now in
terms of its budget right Chancellor
James we haven't heard from you right
Thank You chair and the debate is
destroyed on many parts but obviously is
to ensure that we are financially sound
in the decisions we make obviously we
are running a deficit it's going to get
worse there's no doubt about that
because there's other stuff in the
pipeline the car parking originally much
of Devon actually started again on the
first we delayed it to the 15th to
correspond with the shops opening I
think we can't go on like this tonight
originally I was against the motion
because purely the financial
implications I think when we did decide
to delay the well we didn't stop the car
park and to be precise we just didn't
enforce it for the weeks between the
first of June and the 15th so I think we
are gonna have to move it back now
reject the motion go back to full
council with emotion that's accepted
prepare the
report before we get to full council or
certainly have it ready so we could ever
see in our mid immediately and then if
necessary we'd have to have a full
council which we could all do within the
first two weeks of August
I don't think actually it's gonna make
the scrap a difference to the foot for
all in the town I think at the moment
people aren't going into the town
because they're worried about any spike
or the actual Kovach 19 I think it will
cause more financial embarrassment and
we look at an obviously Steve and I are
both party to some of the finances of
other councils and I will say we've been
torches been leading the way all through
Devon for the last couple of months in
terms of the finances the decisions made
we've been way ahead of most people and
so I don't want to jeopardize that but
on the other hand obviously the strength
of opinion is that we do need to
encourage people into the tone I think
it's a gesture it's not gonna make a lot
of difference and I don't think we will
lose that amount of money because people
aren't going to go in at the moment
anyway so I was proposed that we do need
to reject this rich and I get it back to
full Council which is only just over two
weeks three weeks away the most have the
report ready have an emergency seeing
our and then move forward because I
think if we're going to do something we
need to do to get people into the shops
in the autumn when the holiday season
stops of it and then once we go into
Christmas hopefully the free parking
that's been available in the terms will
become available if if we are allowed to
go down to one meter and people stop
worrying about the not worrying but care
about their own lives and doing the
shopping so that after sort of September
time hopefully there will be free
parking available and hopefully people
will be thinking what we're going into
the turn to do Christmas shopping
so which at this one tonight get it to
full Council which is the 27th how some
of the reports repair so we could that
prepare so we can go straight in to see
and then made that decision on hosting
we get it confirmed but it I there is
financial implications but it is a
catch-22 if people aren't going into the
town then we're not going to lose much
money anyway
and if it does boost the tone of it it
does so I would recommend we do that I
look at Steve and Stacey say how can we
do this as quickly as possible
rather than keep them round around the
circles thank you sure Thank You
councillor James it seems to me that
we've heard the whole debate the whole
argument we're going around in circles
we're not going to get this free parking
in the very near future which was
Jackson amigaos main object in the
initial I believe whether we like it or
not the Constitution is there many of us
disagree with it regularly hate but it
is there and it's there for a reason
I think we've now got to the position of
taking the vote on the motion as written
and seeing see what the result of that
is either then it goes to the full
council as written or Chancellor my golf
tomorrow depth sedan he'll one and
though I will confirm that I will call
an emergency seeing our meeting okay see
if I just
come in a think counselor Bushby
seconded comes to the mag offs motion
but I don't think Councilman God had
proposed it so I don't think you've got
a proposal and or a second as yet
although councillor James made a
proposal to reject the motion oh right
cancel my golf would you formally
propose your motion tighter miss
chairman yeah no I I did formally
propose emotion in cats is pushing its
second bit that was done in the interim
period of it of the councillor James I
said sorry sorry they leave there though
he's obviously is right to try secure
his position as a leader than the
finance chair so that's his job to do so
I will not be voting against this motion
tonight I voted for emotion because it
staff to go against your motion and
tomorrow I will obviously if it gets
defeated today I will down submit
tomorrow morning a new motion to go back
but long you know I just stressed
earlier on you know I did ask for these
options to be presented to the
councillors deceive me it I wasn't done
so being the report saying so long put
together I reckon this report be done it
should be done within a day we got some
bright cookies on it Sora's in the
finance department and it won't take
long to do so as you've already had
plenty of warning that this is coming
because I did ask you back along on it
by more than happy to put submit another
one of this gets for you tonight
okay proposed and seconded I'm going to
put it to the vote it's got to be a
recorded vote
I hand over to Sandra Thank You chair
penciler Brenton
so I'm sorry while we act acting coding
for male then to reject God's motion as
proposed as pro theater so this is all
day park all day free parking that's how
we read it admit both miss mr. chairman
it says for free parking no this is why
I come back in a point of this why
mention it's a committee before it even
came to the extraordinary me I phoned
you a person mr. chairman explain it to
you I spoke to Steve first I spoke to
strong Kearney and I spoke with in my
group as well and the census was two
hours I just say this you know okay it's
open-ended to be you can pick it a bit
bigger as far as much you can but it's
open-ended for a reason to give us that
chance to put the nail in the coffin is
this you've got any things open yourself
I know the way it works then well we're
going around in circles nice imported we
have a proposal and the second o to your
motion us but on the paper
yes wording us Pro the paper
yeah very you to charity you want me to
take the recorded vote now yes please
okay thank you case of Brenton or Khosla
bright or
hence the Bushby
pensive Bushby boy yes for Thank You
Chancellor Christie I can't cancel a
dart
against canceler hicks against
councillor hutchins for canceler james
against cats no laws against hence no
law against cancer McGough for thank you
one two three five six that's five for
the motion and six against motion is
lost
okay thank God I didn't have to do a
custom date Dermot it's your job to get
the paperwork sorted out to get that in
I would suggest you liaised with Shawn
and Steve in the morning and we will
call the new CNR as soon as we can and
Ozzy thank you those council vote the
for it I appreciate that you do your bit
futurus Frankie chair I would say that
in fact goes through that route that I
would also cause an extraordinary
meeting for full council to wear ratify
whatever the CNR decide okay so we move
it along quickly thank you right well I
think at this stage we can declare the
meeting closed thank you so much